Great. This is the Lecture 4.2 on coordinated representation. The goal today will do a quick
recap about multimodal joint representation, what we discussed on Tuesday. Then start discussing
coordinated representation. And to study one, or in fact quite a few of these, I like to do a mini
tutorial reminder on multivariate statistical analysis, including multivariate and covariance.
And then that will allow us to study some one very popular approach, which is the canonical
correlation analysis as an extension to the simple just correlation analysis. And also some of the
future extension that came after that, including deep CCA and deep CCA to encoder. I will also
look at multiview clustering. It's a very interesting aspect of a more almost unsupervised
approach on how do you analyze multiple multimodal or multi-view data. And then look at interesting
paper that is also one of the reading assignment. I will just give a high-level intuition about
this paper. So it brings some interesting aspect. Within the spectrum of multimodal coordinated
representation, CCA may be a little bit closer to joint representation or to encoder is a little
bit closer to the unconnected, completely unconnected views. Quick rip cap. We look at quite a few
last week on Tuesday. We discuss the generative models. Generative models are interesting because
they allow you if learn and train within the details on how to do training, which we'll discuss
more in about three or four weeks. But if you can train a generative model, the interesting aspect
is that you can almost translate in any direction. So you can generate from image, generate images
condition on the text or on the opposite, you can generate text condition on the image because
the advantage is that we because we model the full joint distribution between X and Y, that allows
us to do a lot of these interesting conditional probability or translation tasks. We can use
these representations that we learn either through generative models like those machine or some
other ones, which we'll discuss others unsupervised approaches. And then once you have these, then
what's interesting is that you can later on just learn maybe one or two layers on top of it to do
another task like a supervised learning task. In this case of the paper was looking at the image
retrieval from that. We look at another way to train these joint representations in an unsupervised
way, one of them being stack or to encoder. And if you remember, you can learn end-to-end in this
case, the loss function is a two part level loss function. One is how well you generate text, how
way do you generate images. You can train it with both image and input as image and text as input,
or you could decide to train it just with the image as input, but still have your loss as text
and image. I think that was one of the questions at the end. There's also the idea of learning these
intermediate representation with the feed forward neural network where you are doing a translation
task. So here you're not looking at training or learning the joint, but more of the conditional
probability. And so you're using in this case like the image and encoder image to be able to
generate the text. That's for like example, here is image captioning. And so at this point then the
middle representation is expected to be an intermediate representation between text and image. In practice,
often this one may be closer to the text or closer to the image. There's nothing that
enforces it to be really a joint representation, but it is differently somewhere in between image
and text. And then we discussed at the fact that some of these representations don't explicitly model
like all of the different ways you can interact. And so we look at bi-linear models. One example of
that was the tensor fusion network, which allowed us to do both unimodal and bi-modal. And although
it increases kind of the number of parameters, it allows us that each of these are a little bit
more representative. So it may end up being easier for the later stages of the network to find out
which either unimodal or bi-modal features are the most useful for the task. So and that's also
aligned with some architectures where sometimes the input in even in the multi-layer perceptron,
sometimes people will extend the number of neurons before finally summarizing. That's maybe a
little bit the same intuition you should have here. But how can we learn even better representation?
I think better is probably debatable, but it's different type of representation. Coordinated
is this other type. And if you remember coordinated, the idea is that not only instead of failing and
finding only one joint representation, then maybe you alone one representation for each
modality and you find a way to coordinate it. We talk about ways to coordinate it very strongly
at the end of the meeting on Tuesday where you ask them to be the same almost with cosine distance
being your last function. And this is although it's sometimes called unsupervised learning,
the unsupervised learning is a little bit misleading because it still needs some supervision in this
time is the pair. The pairing between image and text is still needed to be able to learn these two
separate representation. I call them separate, but because they depending on which similarity
metric you use, if it's a very strong like cosine distance, these will almost be equivalent.
So and we show the example and that's the same example that we showed at the beginning. And now
we can probably understand it much better what is happening because really what it was is that
you had paired data of image and text and for each you have an image in the description of the text.
And so from the image, you may get a CNN that encodes it up to maybe in fact the input, maybe
just the CNN features, and the input here could be just the word to VEC average over the whole
sentence. And then the goal is to learn from these new representations in such a way that they
as close as possible, their angles as close as possible. And when you do these, that was the beauty
of this 2014 paper where they were able to train on the pair data and then test time go ahead and
take an image and push it forward, like in the feed forward, push it forward, push it this image
forward there, get their representation, take the word blue, take its representation, take the word
red, take its representation, and then do some arid metric. And then you can sample from there
the kind of images that are the closest. Now you can understand better that,
via the paper, this visual semantic embedding paper, and you could do it on the day and night.
Now these will not work perfectly, and that's one of the issues of this. They need to, although
they are trained to be close to each other, they will not work for every possible word. This,
you cannot just do minus day plus color, so then suddenly you will become in a space that is no more
the same region. So this arid metric is not perfect, but it's nice to see some of this working.
When you train these, you can also train them, and I think one of them is even a paper,
either an optional paper or reading assignment, is the idea of also keeping ordering when you
learn those structures. So you have those two embeddings, and then you say, I want them to
be coordinated somehow. And maybe you say, hey, every caption, I want them to have cosign
similarity between image and captions. That's the way we just described. Or you could just say,
order embedding. So this case is that it's more of a structured way to putting that coordination.
You may want, in fact, that if it is the same entity at a very high level, that these two are
about persons, then yes, they are close to each other. Maybe the caption talk about,
I don't know, a farmer, and the image is a skier. So the farmer in the skier, in a sense, they're
not exactly the same, but at a very high level, they're both people. And so the entity,
the idea here is that these should still be related, these two examples, but maybe not as
closely as if they were talking about a skier and language and also seeing a skier. And so that's
a little bit the intuition with this kind of more structured approach into this. And another way of
doing it is to say, I have these text and these images. And the way I will connect them together
is through some kind of coding mechanism, like a hashing table. That will also allow me to be
both efficient and also enforce some of the similarity. It will also be a binarized version
of that similarity, I will force between that. So these are other examples. I want to also discuss
about CCA and some of the others, but for that, I need to introduce or remind you about some of
the things you, I'm sure you're learning undergrad, but I want to just be sure we're all on the same
page. And it's about multivariate statistical analysis as a building tool for these coordinated
representation. So multivariate statistical analysis, sorry, statistical approaches to understand the
relationship in high dimensional data, multivariate is, you can see it as multiple variables or high
multiple dimensions in your data. Example, a very popular, there's the ANOVA and then there's the
multivariate version of ANOVA, the MANOVA, PCA and factor analysis are other approaches under the
umbrella of multivariate. And then LDA, a linear discriminant analysis, I will not discuss as much
although, but it's a good reminder if you could look at it also and we'll discuss CCA in a second.
But the core of this are random variables, random variables, a variable whose possible values are
numerical outcomes of a random phenomena. And as you probably remember from previous courses on
this topic, there's two types of random variable, discrete random variable. In this case, the values
that these random variables can take are discrete, so 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, or they could even be colors or
age or other type of, so it could be a tribute or numerical. Continuous will be when it's an
infinite number of value, continuous value. So example, someone's age, someone's height,
someone's weight, age could be represented as a continuous, but age is sort of often represented
as a discrete variable, height could also be continuous, but often it's like, oh, I'm 5 feet,
11 or something, and the weight similarly would discretize a lot of these. And by the interesting
thing is also which one are correlated with each other, age may be correlated at least at the
beginning, age with height and weight, height and weight by themselves could also be correlated.
So correlation is a very interesting aspect when we look at random variable. So given two random
variable, I want to define a few terms, expected value, that's something you will hear quite often,
and I want to be sure that you have a mental image of it. It's the probably weighted average
of the values. So if it's a discrete space, so I have all my possible values, and here it's for
the discrete case here, but for all my possible values, and it's multiplied, I have a discrete
number of these values, and it's multiplied by how the probability of that value itself
is happening. And in many cases, that probably may be just equal for everybody. So in that case,
what is it equal to? And it's just if it's the same for all observation, then this is exactly the
same as just an Android metric mean. So the expected value could be seen as the mean in many cases,
but if some samples or some values are more likely than others, then this will allow us to take this
into consideration. So variance comes as the next version after that, that measure the spread of my
observation. So it is the expected value of your data minus the mean n squared. And so that's the
variance of your data. Variance is equal to the square of the standard deviation. That's another
way to see it. Variance is going to be important when we also start looking at covariance and also
at correlation. A lot of time, if your data is already normalized, or if you already removed the
mean, then your variance is just almost a multiplication of your data, if the data is already centered
in this case. The covariance is where things start being interesting, because you measure how
two random variables change together. And that's interesting. So you have one random variable,
you have another one, and then you're trying to see how are these two run like, how are these two
changing together. Here at this point, all of this is for univite, like I'm not yet doing the multivite,
but in a second we'll show that. But if it's only x is one dimensional and y is one dimensional,
and you remove the mean, so you remove the mean from both of them, and then then your question is
like, hey, how is the, if my x is suddenly increasing, how is my y changing? And if my y is changing,
how is the x changing? So that's the, and that's, if it is already normalized data,
then it's only the multiplication of the two. So the multiplication will become important,
because multiplication, the correlation is just a normalized version of the covariance. The
correlation, which measure the extent to which two variables have a linear relationship with
each other, really what they're doing is just a normalized version. It's looking at the covariance,
it's like how much do they change together, but you just normalize it unlike how much x change
by itself, and how much y no changes by itself. By normalizing it, what's the nice thing is the
correlation will be between one and minus one. So you get and get a nice, because you normalize it
correctly nicely. So let's do a little test of these. If x is the horizontal axis and y is the
vertical axis, and I show you a plot like this one, will you say x and y are both, and each dot
there is one of my sample. So these are scattered to graph, that's one way to call them,
and these are each of my plot. And while if I have something like this, will you say they're
correlated? And so in this case, it's very strongly correlated. Every time there's, in fact it's,
you could say positively correlated. So every time there's an increase in x, there's also an
increase in y. And as you get here, they're very scattered all around, and so at that point you
lose and don't have a strong correlation. So this was a bit easier. Now this one,
so this one we knew is positive correlated. Yeah, these are also correlated.
So yes, in fact, these are still very correlated. It is still very strongly correlated. It's just
that the correlation is, there's still a strong correlation. So every time one is changing,
the other is changing. And the important part here is that fact that in the Pearson correlation,
we were normalizing by each, like variance of x and variance of y. And for that reason,
even though it looks like, I don't know, one is maybe more correlated than the other,
but because you divide by variance of x and variance of y, then they end up having almost
or exactly like both a correlation of one. The only one is the middle one, which is undefined,
because at that point, if you always get no variation in one of your x or y, then if you
remember the equation, you divide by the variance of x and the variance of y. And if that variance is
zero, there's no change, then it becomes undefined divided by zero. And then you have a bunch of other
graphs here. And that will be part of your homework. And I'm just kidding. But yeah,
these, I will say, are less correlated or very little correlated, although it would maybe be
tempting to call this correlated. But these are, I will say maybe not exactly zero, but the very
uncorrelated. Okay, so multivariate is an extension from that. So I talk about univviates, or in
your universe, you have, let's say, age and the weight, and then you're looking at this. But in many
cases, you have multiviodes. So x and y may be like x may be language, and x1 may be looking at
sentiment of the in the language, x2 may be looking at, I don't know the, is it about the past or the
present I'm talking about. So this could be all of these from lexicon, like L.I.W.C, like description
of the language. And maybe in the image, I could be looking at features like, is it about a person?
Is the person smiling? Where are they looking? So these are a bunch of feature random variables.
And so each of these, you could, a lot of time we call them features in a non statistical way,
we'll just call them features. And so if for one view x and one view x and one view y,
or one modality x and one modality y. And then the everything we described earlier,
it will still exist in the multivariate sense. So one thing is the covariance matrix,
which is like within one modality, within modality x, how are these different random variable,
how are these different features related to each other? So when I change, I don't know the
sentiment, does it change also the way, I don't know how often I talk about the future,
like how often I use the, I don't know, first person pronouns. And so is there very, are they
varying together or not? I mean, this matrix, the diagonal of this matrix will be how each
of them are varying with each other. So it would be one. And then if really nothing, none of them
vary with each other, then all of the of diagonal would be zero. So that's what you get with a
covariance matrix. The more interesting is the cross covariance matrix, because now it's not
comparing x with itself, but it's looking at x and y. And so for looking at how, like if the
language, if the sentiment is very positive, how does it change with me being a man or a woman,
or me being smiling or not in the image, or me having a certain age, or me like, so how is all
these features that I have, how do they vary to each other? How often do I get more of the positive,
how does it change on having more smiles? And so that's what this matrix is going to be. And so
this is going to be an interesting matrix. This matrix is, and to show it visually, this matrix,
the same, the diagonal will be how x1 and y1 vary to each other, yx1 and y2. The thing is,
the ordering should not matter as much. So I should like, if I can't reshape the,
re-swap the order of this, although after I decided on order, then I should be consistent
afterward. But here, like x1 versus x2 is just arbitrary. I pick x1 to be the positive words,
and x2 may be negative words. But the more interesting is to look like inside this,
how is these correlated with the other modality? So this is the covariance. And I'm just going to,
before I get into the CCA, which looks at correlation with this, which, as you remember,
correlation, what was correlation? Correlation was covariance of x and y divided by the variance of
x times the variance of y. So it's going to be, in matrix like this, divided by matrix like this,
multiplied by the matrix of the y. So you can already know how the covariance,
the correlation could be computed. Now, I just want to define that the trace is defined as the
sum of the element of the diagonal. I just want to define that. So by the way, the trace here,
what would be the trace? Because here is the trace is one, like the diagonal is always one.
And so the trace will just be the multiplication of these, which is,
so that's the trace, does the diagonal of this. But the more, so PCA is what you all know or have
worked with in this kind of multivariate world. PCA is, the idea is that you have two set of points,
point clouds are, or scatter plots. And so you have samples. And let's say, for now, I have,
here, I have, PCA, I will do it on one point cloud. So I have one point cloud, maybe all my
language data. I have all my language data. And let's say I have only two viable x and y, okay,
and x and y. And so principal component analysis is this idea that although x and y were looking at,
I don't know, positivity, and I don't know what would be this one, like language, another language
features. And then, although I have defined these features, and that's how I measure it,
that's maybe not how the variance is happening. And so PCA is about looking where is the variance
happening? What is that direction where most of the variance is happening? And clearly,
most of the variance is around this axis. And so that will be called your first eigenvector.
And then the second eigenvector will always be perpendicular to the first one. And that one
will have less variance happening there. So this is a lot more interesting to study this. If I was
to look at factor analysis, I will probably also study this kind of where the variance is happening.
So officially, PCA converts a set of observations of possibly correlated volume to a set of value,
which are linearly-encrolated variables called principal components. And so I showed it for two
different point clouds here. Eigenvectors are the orthogonal. And the first couple of eigenvector
usually explain most of this. And the low eigenvector, low eigenvalues mean less information. And so
maybe it's just noise that is there. So maybe I could just remove the noise. Eigenvalue decomposition.
I want to describe it because we will reuse it when we talk about CCA. So if you have a matrix A
of n by n, is there exists a non-zero vector x in such a way that a at a time x is a scalar
multiplying multiply of x. So this is another way to say it is that I have my matrix A that I'm trying
to learn what is the eigenvector. And if I multiply by an eigenvector, then I should be able to be
equal to multiplying the same eigenvector by the eigenvalues. That's the intuition mathematically
with one way of solving it is in such a way that if I have that, if I found that, if I have my
original scattered data all around and I was to find this one eigenvector, then the multiplying
by the eigenvalue would be equivalent to multiplying all of my data by that eigenvector. So that was
another intuition. And that was nice to say there to solve these. There has been a lot of interesting
ways to solve this. One of it is single value, the composition taking your matrix A and decomposing
it in columns U. The columns of U are the eigenvectors of A times A transpose and V are the eigenvector
of A times A transpose A. And so this is, I'm going a little bit fast on this. This is probably for
most of you just a quick reminder that of these. But the thing that you may or may not have worked
on as much is canonical correlationization analysis. And this is very interesting because
in many problems in where you have multi-view learning, you have some demographic and then some
response to surveys. And so you're trying to match how the demographic align with different
aspects of surveys. Or in all case, is that you have audio and video and you want to see how these
correlated to each other. And that's really for us. When I think of multi-view, I think of multi-model
when the more general says is multi-view is could be for any type of data.
So canonical is about reduce to the simplest or clearest schema of possible. And so correlation
analysis goes in three steps. And so I have my text and I have my images. And for now, I could
call it unsupervised, but it is really paired data. So it has some kind of supervision. I have
this paired data. And my goal is to learn and embedding where these embedding, these representation
for image and text are going to be as correlated as possible. That's the first intuition. But it's
not the exact one and I'm going to clarify it. But at a high level, you could say I want to have
these embedding as correlated as possible. That correlated mean is there's increase in one,
then I also increases in the other, or if it's positive correlated or negatively correlated.
So if it was, this is the idea is to learn two linear projection. So I have my features for
X, my feature for Y, so text and images. And I want to project them. And for now, I will just go
with linear CCA, which says I have a linear projection. So I'm going to, I have already my
embedding, maybe of Word2vec and CNN. And I just want to learn a linear projection of the two.
But I want to learn these projections so that these two projections, and my projection,
I really mean representation or embeddings, these two projections are as correlated as possible.
And that's the first way. And that's, if I was just to do this, it would not be called
canonical correlation analysis, it would be called correlation analysis, because this is just how
these two are as most correlated. But isn't there, and this is, I say here that it's the two embeddings
that are correlated, but mathematically, it's also, you can imagine that it's the projection. So I
have my X, and I project it, and then I want these projections to be as correlated as possible.
So this is the first step, and just the intuition there is I want these to be as correlated. So I
have X and Y, and X and Y are, let's say for now, I have my, I have paired data, and for the X and
the Y, and let's say for now, I X and Y are in 2D, X, Y is in 2D, and X is also in 2D. And the correlation
is such a way that if there is an increase in X in some direction, that they will also be an
increase similarly in Y. That's the main idea is that you find it that every time that if there
is a change in X, it also has a similar change in Y. That's the idea of correlation. So maybe
if I have a loud, very, let's say that X was about audio, and V was here, the audio in the visual.
So it says stronger, very strong loudness, and also maybe high pitch, very strong
loudness and high pitch, and in visual, what you see is an increase in eyebrows, but a decrease in
smile. There is a lot less smile, but there's an increase in eyebrows. So eyebrows goes up,
and but a reduction in smile, every time that there is a very, very strong,
and like I may say, maybe every time there's a reduction in my loudness, and my example here
was pitch. Although the example I was imagining was closer to being this way. So maybe the next
time I present it, I will show it that way. So this is the correlation. This is just if it was
correlation analysis, but in our case, and that's the beauty of Canonical correlation analysis,
is that I will not just learn it. And this is the same Canonical correlation here. I'm just re,
oh, sorry, before I get into the second one, I just want to remind you correlation
is covariance and variance of each of them. So how well did they vary to each other?
They're just normalized by each of them. And if they are, these are already normalized,
then you can rename, we can rewrite this, because if the data has been already normalized,
here what I did is just a rewriting is like, there is this data, initial data that I have,
and then I projected this I Y, and that gave me my H Y. I took my X and I projected it and gave
my H X, and then similarly for the variance on X, variance on Y. So I'm doing this just because it's
kind of everybody will often change the notation to something like this, which is like your covariance
matrix and your cross covariance matrix and your covariance matrix. Here's, and so you often will
see it this way, but this equation are exactly the same with just the normalized data. Now the,
the reason I go there is that I want to say that the second intuition is that I have H X and H Y,
and I could say, hey, I want them to be as correlated as possible, but there may be more than one way
this data can be correlated, and it has a beauty of canonical correlation analysis is to say,
there's more than, maybe more than one way that the data could be correlated, and so we want these
multiple projection of it, of the data, and so you have this data, and I will find multiple
projection. Each of these projections will be also going to, with each other, so I'm going to learn
like these multiple projection, but I will learn them in such a way that my first one may be the
most correlated, the second one is the second most correlated and third one, third most correlated,
and so the beauty of it is that there may be more than one way H X and H Y will be correlated,
and then I just need to find a way to enforce that these will be orthogonal or canonical, so
by canonical is the simplest, and how to make it simple is to make it orthogonal. If you didn't
make it canonical, then they could be like these could be like, but now if you make it canonical,
then they're all, and that what it means canonical and mostly mean that H X one, if I multiply one by
the other, then it should be zero. That's the idea, and so another way to make it is to say
that this whole thing, if everything, here's a, it takes a little while to realize it,
but I want them to be canonical, what it means is that H X, if I take two of them,
they should be zero, if they are, if they are two different one, there should be zero,
otherwise they should be non-zero. So this whole matrix, in fact, I'm going to force it to be zero,
and I'm only going to focus on the center part of it, on the trace, and so because everything else
I want it to be zero, and so I want only focusing on the trace. And so I can rename, and we can
rewrite it this way, saying I'm going to focus only on the trace, but I'm also, because if you
don't add this other one, I'm also going to make it in such a way that since this subject is
invariance and scale, I want to add this constraint that these should be equal to identity.
I will make it as a constraint, and then when I do it and make it as they are equal to identity,
I'm also enforcing that the off-dangle of this are zero. I'm forcing it by having this one there.
And so the canonical correlation analysis can be written as maximizing the trace,
that's really what I'm maximizing, in such a way that the covariance are unit and entity matrix,
and also that the off-dangle are zero. So that's what I want to optimize.
And so how do I see this visually? This, specifically this part here, how do I can show it visually?
I'm doing it in such a way that all of my off, I make it so that here, I make it so that these
are identity, and I'm making it so that these are off-dangle are zero, and then I am optimizing
to maximize these. I want these as large as possible. So I want as these as large as possible,
while keeping all of this zero, and then an identity for the variance here. And so how do you
solve this? And I don't know if you're probably a little while you look at this optimization problem,
but when you see maximize and then subject to some constraints, you can probably know that one of
the waiters optimize this is Lagrange multiplier, which is translated as the barn, the multiplier
of the barn, but no Lagrange is probably the last name of the mathematician who did this.
And there, what it is, is the idea of this is that you Lagrange function that is defined as
what you're trying to maximize, and then it has two, apart with each of them has these Lagrange
multiplier, and these Lagrange multipliers will allow you to define those stationary points,
and I'm not going in all of the detail, but once you get this into a function, which is,
this is your last function, then now I can start an optimizing like you do optimizing many of them
by looking at how they change, look at their gradient, and then when for you do from that,
when you force them to be a zero as a stationary point, then you can get this. This is just some
simple interesting mathematics that goes. But what's interesting in this is that it is in fact very
related to SVD, to solve for this equation is in fact very related to SVD, because what you have
is these eigenvectors, and then these eigenvalues here, so you can solve CCA with SVD decomposition,
and so the SVD can nicely take on, and so you can take this part here, and that will give you
the decomposition. So the canonical correlation analysis, the nice aspect of it, is that it finds
multiple ways that things are correlated. So in the spectrum of coordinated representation,
I'm not forcing the representation to be cool to each other, I'm not forcing them to be completely
correlated to each other, which will be kind of equivalent to just saying, multiplying,
it's almost the same as the other, but here you're saying, hey, that there's more than one way that
they can be correlated. It's still in the big scheme of thing, it's still relatively close to
joint representation, but it allows a little bit more loose coordination to that. So these are the
three main intuition for canonical correlation analysis. So linear projection that maximizes
the correlation, but each of these projections are orthogonal, and you make it the unit variance
of the projection vector. The unit variance was also something we would do if you remember for the
word to beck when we were comparing the projection. So now this is CCA, what's really nice is like,
let's look at extension that are nonlinear version of this. So the paper in 2013 that got
quite popular, it was an extension of CCA to make it nonlinear version.
And in this case, it's not just the linear projection, but I would also have a nonlinear,
and I'm only putting one nonlinearity, but it could be many more of them. And so the objective
function is still to make my loss function, and because I have paired data, my loss function here
is still going to be about the correlation of these two to be as correlated as possible,
because if it's paired data, I know that this sample X is supposed to co-occur with Y,
and so I will want there to be as correlated as possible. And for this, you need to compute the
gradient of these between H of X and the U. And then you can, after that, once you've done that,
as long as you get that gradient, which we talked about in the previous slide,
that this is something that can be analytically computed, then it's a gradient-based approach,
and deep neural representation are all about analytical gradient. So if I can get an analytical
gradient, then I can propagate my gradient, and then everything goes well. What is the beauty of
it is that you can learn and just pre-train, and that was more like specifically how they did it
in that paper. That paper came not too long after the multimodal deep learning paper. So at that point,
there was this idea which is still now very popular in language, which is the idea of pre-training,
which is the idea of let's pre-train on maybe a larger amount of data. So maybe you can pre-train
on a text base where I have multiple nonlinear representation, nonlinear projection, and maybe
a linear projection. And then eventually, I'm going to middle representation in such a way
that I can recreate my text. I can pre-train that way, and then that allows me, after that,
to fine-tune it. So I can fine-tune maybe just a linear projection, or I can fine-tune all of them.
Now, CCA, one of the challenges of CCA is that it's correlation. And if I give you
one sample like an image and a text, I give you just two samples, one sample from each modality,
and I say, what is the correlation? I don't know. You're looking at an image of LP, and I don't know,
and I don't know, like brown eyes. Is there a correlation? It's only two samples you can't.
The correlation is undefined. And so the correlation needs a lot of samples.
So if you are to do a batch-based approach, it becomes very important to do large mini batches,
or full batches, and then you do something like the Newton that we talked about.
What's really interesting of that paper and extension of that paper is to start and not only
pre-train with an autoencorder and then do the CCA, but you can do it together. And that I think
is really interesting. What is the loss function here? Look at this model. What is the loss function?
You have the autoencorder for text, autoencorder of images, and then you have some coordination
between the two. So definitely, h of x should be good in such a way that it creates images,
can recreate the image, or at least the image features, and here you have your representation
in such a way that it can recreate the text feature. But then you also have the loss here.
And so if you are to train it, if you had to start which of these three losses,
so the losses there, the loss will have three parts. How well I generate the text, how well I
generate the image, and how always they correlate them. Training it, you could start with all three
losses equal, you could start maybe with these two stronger, and then eventually you want it to
be as correlated. This is kind of a smooth version of the previous approach. The previous approach,
you do autoencoding, and then you do the CCA. In this one, you're kind of doing all of them
together. But even though you do it together, you may not want to wait all the losses the same
at every iteration during your optimization. So that's another thing to think about.
And so as a CCA, you can always learn the CCA in a stack manner that we discussed before.
I'm not going in the details of LDA and some of these MANOVA. But I will say, in our world,
where everybody is using the same approaches, and we're all based on the same set of tools,
I really invite you to start looking at others. Sometimes they look like old work, but this work
is very strong in the sense that there's been a lot of proofs and there's a lot of interesting
results. And if you look at interpretability as one of the things you want, these statistical
approaches can give you a lot better, and often they will give you interpretability. They also
have bounds into it. And so that really useful information. So let's say, for example,
interconfidence intervals on some parameters. So I invite you to study a little bit more on this
topic. I want to look at a sister topic, which is called multi-view clustering, because we talk
about if you have paired data, so we call it unsupervised data, you have paired data,
and you want to learn a representation. But clustering, and just this one is not yet the
multi-view clustering, it's just a clustering. It's the idea of partition, a set of data samples,
such that similar sample are grouped together, and dissimilar samples are divided. So the nice thing
here, and that's in the world of interpretable models, the idea of data clustering is to not only
learn a representation, but within that representation, what are the clusters, what are the groups on
this? And so the basic version of this is k-mean clustering, and this is a simple clustering based
on competitive learning, where things can be part of only one of the k-groups, and it's an iterative
process. So it's a sign, the idea is you're randomly usually, or you can have a warm start,
but you can randomly set the middle of each group, and then you, for all the examples,
assign them into one of the group, the closest one, and then you recompute the center of the cluster,
and you do it until convergence. Winners takes out, that's why it's competitive. The subversion of that
is a non-negative matrix factorization. So the idea here is you have a matrix X,
and then you want to factorize this in such a way where what you want is a non-negative matrix F,
and matrix G. And so in this case, you could say you will have some kind of basis or factors,
and then you will have some coefficient for these factors. So you could see it also maybe as G
being those different centers of the clusters, and F being as how much each of these columns of X
each of these samples, how much is it part of each of these. So G will have, let's say, let's say,
10 different center clusters, let's say, 10 different center clusters, and let's say you have
100 samples in X, and so it will say for my first sample in X, how much is it part of the first
cluster, how much is it part of the second cluster, how much is it part of the third cluster,
that's the kind of nice soft clustering that I'm talking about. And this F, it makes sense the most
when the F is, in fact, non-negative, because in that case, if it's non-negative, then it's really
how much I'm part of that first cluster, how much I'm part of the second cluster.
And so for this, there's been a nice and interesting extension of that. SVD does
the composition, but this one is not necessarily non-negative. In that typical non-negative
metric structureization, both the G and the F are going to be positive. In the semi-non-negative,
then maybe just one of them is, and the second one will be positive. If you go with the example I
was saying, then then the F, how much is it part, I could be also negative or positive,
and then there's the context version of that. Just the semi-non-negative is interesting,
because I like it, because it also, you can go be both positive and negative in the way
each of my cluster are defined, and you can do it in a deep way. So there's a nice paper on a deep
semi-negative metric factorization, and it's deep. They call it deep, but it could be like
multi-factors, and you kind of have NMF for one factor, NMF for another, NMF for third one,
and that's deep in that sense. I will say one direction I like is the idea of
learn the data partition from multiple view. So up to now, this is just about looking at this
clustering, but what if I have multiple view? That's interesting. So it's not just I have all my
language data, and I want to cluster it, like the classic is topic modeling. I have a bunch of
web pages, and I want to know topics that are discussed, but here it's interesting is I have
maybe the text of these, and I may also have images in these web pages. I can also have maybe audio
associated with it, and I want to do the clustering based on all those three modalities. That's the
interesting part, and for now, let's say that I have paired data. So I know that in instance,
I know that each instance I come from the same audio text and images for now, and so the principle
of multi-view clustering, two important principle, is the first one is consensus principle. You want
to maximize what is consistent across multiple view. You want to group together information
that is, so in each modality, I can have many dimensions, many features, but I'm going to,
let's say I have for view one, I have a lot of features, and for view two, I have a lot of features,
but there's a subset of these features that have a consensus, and so that they are like
similar, but also multiple views need to get more comprehensive and accurate
description, so there's also that each, there's complementarity in between the view, so there's
consensus and there's complementarity, and so the multi-view subset clustering, which is
one way, one type or one approach, learns a unified feature representation from all of you
subspace by assuming that all of you share this one representation, so you have all of these views
that have a subspace for it, so it's like kind of an embedding for each, and then you're doing it
in such a way you learn this subspace so that it learn to be able to predict that unified
representation, and so how to end for data clustering in our multimodal data, which is very interesting,
so I have this multiple modalities and I want to make it in such a way that data can be easily
clustered, so I want a learner representation of text and a learner represent an image in such a
way that there will be a natural clustering in my data, and that cluster will be consistent
across modality, and so one fact, one paper that you invited to look at, which was one of the early
one in that direction, was the deep metrics factorization, which you have a visual,
you have visual features, you have in this case the language was represented in a discrete way,
and these two will be taken together, here the one will be embedded, but then finally you will
find this way in such a way that there is a nice factorization of your data, and then if you do
that at test time, it also helps you at test time for the image tagging in this case. I invite you
to look at these other approaches, because I don't have time to discuss all the different ways,
because one way that we look at it is as a subspace, and then the subspace in such a way that there
is a nice grouping, but you could also have in it a graph, so the sub embeddings of each view is in
fact a graph, and you want to do it such that the graph has a nice way of being clustered,
and that's a little bit closer to what we discussed also last Tuesday, and so I invite you to look at
these approaches, and it's really nice because you can do that in such a way that you can also
bootstrap between this, so this is just the idea that you will do the clustering, you get some knowledge
of it, and then you use that knowledge for another modality, get the clustering, and then do the
knowledge and do this, this is kind of a co-training way to do that. Okay, the last part of the lecture
that I want to discuss today, this is about the auto encoder, auto encoder, and so, and this is an
extension, and in the spectrum of coordinated, so we talk about having very strong coordination,
like cosine similarity, we talk about correlation, we talk about canonical correlation, we talk about
clustering, which I would say is like a little bit loosely, so even graph base, and here we'll talk
about having it about, it has a little bit of that same intuition of latent space, but it's a nice
extension of that, so just the quick reminder of the deep CCA, the deep CCA is the idea that you
learn, you have an auto encoder, and you have an auto encoder, and then you force it to be, at the
same time you have a third loss, that also makes it that is correlated with orthogonal projections,
but multi-view latent intact space is, the intuition there is that, for good or for bad,
it's the intuition that there is this non-noisy, like this like real intact representation space
that exists, and then each modality or each view is kind of a slice of that, plus some noise, like
that makes it so, and one view of that is like I have an intent, I really want you guys to love
multi-modal machine learning, and understand coordinated representation, so that's my intent,
and that's in my brain, you don't observe that, but there is this intact, oh I don't know, hopefully
intact, space that I have of representation that I have, but when I talk, this is me sharing,
this is a view of what's not visible, but this is a small view of what's not visible,
and you see my expression and you hear my voice, and all of these are all different view of that
same intact space, so I have this intact space, and I said something, you see my non-verbal
microistic, and that gives you a noisy version of what I wanted to say, that's the first intuition
I want to share, which is the intuition of intact space, the other one which is even cooler for this
model is that that intact space is different for every instance, so if you look at the first five
minutes of this lecture, I had one message I wanted to share, that was my intact space for that first
five minutes, but the next five minutes, and now this current five minutes, I have another intact
space, and so at every time I have this new intact space, and it's a different,
I had a different intent at each of these five minutes, I have a different intent,
and you see a different view of that, so if I was to call it like H, my intent, my hidden intent,
and it's intact, it's clear, it's in my brain, it's clear what I want to share with you,
but HI is different for, not I, here's the different views, but that H is going to change
at each instance, so there's an intact representation, which is complete, not damaged,
but the views are only partial representation of that, that's the first intuition, so the
auto-encoder of a two-encoder, auto-encoder in a two-encoder, is you have an auto-encoder,
that's the typical auto-encoder, so it goes ahead and encode your data and decode it,
but, and then I have this intact, like this intent, and I have it intent, and for each,
for each instance in my training, it may be different, that's another part of the intuition,
and so the idea is for each, for each instance, I will take this, this intact thing that is
joined, joined for both of them, and I will, I will degrade it, to degrade it for the text,
and degrade it for the, for the language, for the image, in such a way that the degraded representation
of what I really wanted to say to you, that degraded representation has the nice, it should be as
close as possible to that representation here, and, and then I also at the same time, one minus,
so I have four losses, I have my two or two-encoder losses, but the beauty of here is that I, I'm,
the way I'm coordinating it, is that, is that I will force it to be, always have something in
comment that I can degrade and be close to each other, and, and the total loss has both of them,
and, and the latent, there is also this latent variable age, and the, the minimization here
is going to be challenging, because age will also, at test time, that would takes a little bit,
but at test time, age will also need to be inferred, because it is, is not observed, age is not observed,
and so at test time, and at training time, but at test time, usually age, you would like it to be
a parameter, but at, in practice, age can be a test time also inferred, from that, and you may need
some interactive way to do that, so, so that's the two-encoder, and so in the scheme of things,
you can see how this one has a less of a clear match, I mean, these, I don't need to be matching
or exactly, it's just that there's a degraded, maybe sometimes it's more degraded than others
that goes with it, so thank you very much for your attention,